[Música]
cada cuatro años los colombianos son
convocados a las urnas para elegir a su
presidente y como el clima de la capital
este año los resultados para conocer
quién reemplazará a iván duque de
derecha en la casa de nariño son
impredecibles bienvenidos aquí américa
para esta emisión especial sobre las
elecciones en colombia unos comicios en
los que el poder podría ir de un extremo
a otro del espectro político y colombia
podría tener por primera vez un
presidente de izquierda acompáñenme a
entender por qué
38 millones de ciudadanos están llamados
a elegir entre siete candidatos pero los
que más posibilidades tienen según las
encuestas locales están en polos
opuestos gustavo petro en la izquierda y
federico gutiérrez en la derecha por el
centro sergio fajardo sin embargo sus
detractores de izquierda lo tildan de
favorecer a la derecha y los de derecha
viceversa en la recta final de la
campaña tomó fuerza la candidatura del
ingeniero rodolfo hernández un
empresario que ataca a los partidos
políticos tradicionales pero al no
contar con apoyos en el congreso
probablemente tenga que hacer pactos con
ellos para gobernar si llegara a la
presidencia la polarización en el país
llega casi seis años después de que el
gobierno colombiano entonces a la cabeza
de juan manuel santos firmara un acuerdo
de paz con la guerrilla de izquierda de
las farc el histórico acuerdo negociado
en la habana cuba- terminó con una
guerra de más de 50 años y convirtió a
uno de los movimientos guerrilleros más
antiguos del continente en y político
hoy paola ramírez está a punto de
convertirse en abogada y hace parte del
partido común es el partido político
nacido tras la desmovilización el tema
de la justicia social para mí fue pues
imperante no no salía y veía todo el
tiempo una cantidad de situaciones de
desigualdad pues horribles sobre todo en
el campo colombiano entonces bueno en la
universidad digamos tuve la oportunidad
de hacer recorridos por el país y demás
y ver pues lo que tenían que vivir los
campesinos las comunidades en unas
situaciones supremamente precarias
entonces pues ya allí digamos en la
universidad pues hay digamos
cercanías y presencia de algunas
organizaciones que pues lograron hacer
pues logré hacer el puente con la con
las farc en ese momento y como te digo
pues me vinculé al trabajo del entonces
partido clandestino como ves tú hoy el
proceso el acuerdo de pases tan está
amenazado sí pues mira lo que pasa es
que a nosotros nos tocó una situación
sui generis
e implementar el acuerdo de paz con un
gobierno que no creía en el acuerdo de
paz un gobierno que lo primero que dijo
es que iba a hacer trizas el acuerdo y
en ese contexto nos tocó implementarlas
los retos se cuentan desafortunadamente
hoy en muertos
esa falta de voluntad política del
gobierno de edu que hoy nos ha parado
frente a una realidad muy compleja y es
la reactivación del conflicto y muchos
de esos territorios que creyeron en la
paz muchas de esas comunidades que
trabajaron y que están esperanzadas hoy
lo que ven es la reactivación del
conflicto armado ante un estado pues que
no hace nada y que dejó que justamente
se comparan que llegarán allí grupos
ilegales y demás entonces creo que el
principal reto pues la voluntad política
del nuevo gobierno para implementar
integralmente el acuerdo de paz
entendiendo que es una herramienta
fundamental o sea yo creo que los
colombianos seguramente no hemos
identificado la potencialidad que tiene
ese acuerdo y la posibilidad y las
herramientas que nos trae para superar
ese conflicto tan largo que hemos vivido
y que esperamos de estas elecciones qué
esperas tú como integrante ahora del
partido comunes de estas elecciones para
lo primero es que yo espero
transparencia y que se garanticen los
mínimos democráticos para que pues la
gente pueda participar y pueda expresar
su voluntad popular y la transparencia
también
conocimiento que identifiquemos las
propuestas y que la gente reconozca que
hay candidatos que hoy lamentablemente
están absolutamente en contra de la paz
así no lo digan textualmente pero hoy
tenemos candidatos que no se van a
complementar con el acuerdo de paz que
lo que de lo que están hablando es de
continuidad pero incluso de negación de
derechos fundamentales un mensaje para
las personas que no creen en el acuerdo
de paz que no creen en la
desmovilización
bueno yo creo que todas las personas que
estamos en proceso de reincorporación
hemos demostrado nuestra voluntad de paz
estamos aquí a pesar de todas las
adversidades a pesar de las amenazas a
pesar de los homicidios a pesar del
incumplimiento
seguimos aquí comprometidos con la paz y
creo que esa es la principal muestra
pues que la paz si es real que es
posible yo creo que el hacer paz no es
solamente firmar un acuerdo el hacer
pases de entender que hay otras formas
de resolver nuestros conflictos pero que
además hay que escuchar hasta colombia
que no se ha escuchado y el acuerdo de
paz justamente tiene esos instrumentos
para devolverle por ejemplo a través de
la reforma rural integral a los
campesinos resolver el problema de la
tierra garantizarle a la gente que ha
sido excluida pues la participación
política y muchos más elementos para
como te digo sentar las bases de la
democracia y garantizar los derechos
fundamentales de las mayorías en el país
[Música]
según el registro único de víctimas más
de 8 millones de colombianos son
víctimas del conflicto armado josé darío
ante que era guzmán era un niño cuando
su padre un líder del partido comunista
colombiano fue asesinado hoy dirige el
centro de paz memoria y reconciliación
fundado durante la administración de
gustavo petro como alcalde de bogotá la
reconciliación es un concepto muy amplio
hay muchas cosas que están contribuyendo
a transformar la cultura política en
colombia algunas pueden ser vistas por
parte de muchos actores de la sociedad
como contrarias a la reconciliación pero
en realidad van en la dirección correcta
porque van en la dirección correcta de
la democracia cuando la sociedad se
moviliza cuando la sociedad expresa su
repudio frente a las violaciones a los
derechos humanos hay un aumento de las
posibilidades de que en colombia haya
alternancia del poder hay un aumento de
las posibilidades de que colombia haya
participación política es combatientes
de que haya el fin de la justificación
que a veces se expresa en muchos
espacios públicos de las violaciones a
los derechos humanos
implica también que a partir del acuerdo
de paz la sociedad colombiana sobre todo
ha tenido mayor posibilidad de
participar políticamente lo que hemos
visto a partir del acuerdo de paz es que
después del acuerdo en 2016 en las
elecciones de 2018 un aumento no tanto
de la participación electoral en sí pero
sí efectivamente de muchas personas
dispuestas a votar por lo que nunca se
había podido votar en colombia que eran
opciones alternativas estigmatizadas
como opciones que estaban o que eran
favorables a las farc en particular
hemos visto después una participación
masiva en la consulta anticorrupción una
participación que seguramente va a ser
masiva también en estas elecciones en
torno a las opciones alternativas y eso
significa un quiebre de la
estigmatización que el colombiano pidió
que durante años se pudiese votar por
opciones de izquierda progresistas a
partir de la corte de paz y tú
precisamente fuiste víctima también de
esa estigmatización de alguna manera
cuál esperas que sea el legado para tu
familia creo que hoy el legado para
nuestra familia más bien es desde
nuestra familia un legado de compromiso
con la solución política del conflicto y
con la búsqueda democracia en el país es
ese nuestro compromiso actual
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la elección presidencial de este año
está marcada además por las
manifestaciones de 2021 el mayor
movimiento de protestas que ha vivido
colombia cuando los ciudadanos salieron
masivamente a las calles inicialmente en
rechazo a la reforma tributaria
propuesta por el gobierno de iván duque
que arremetía contra las clases media y
baja y que derivó tras su archivo en un
reclamo por reformas profundas que
pusieran fin a décadas de desigualdad y
por garantías al derecho a la protesta
en medio de denuncias de violaciones a
los derechos humanos por parte de la
fuerza pública que fueron corroborados
por organizaciones internacionales como
human rightswatch la ciudad de cali en
el sur occidente del país fue el
epicentro de estas manifestaciones y los
jóvenes fueron los protagonistas un
equipo de france 24 se desplazó hasta
allí para conocer a su variada juventud
dividida entre quienes apoyaron el
reclamo y quienes lo condenaron
bueno esta es puerto resistencia a uno
de los puntos más emblemáticos del
estallido social
mayra fue parte de las protestas más
grandes de la historia reciente de
colombia en 2021 cali la tercera ciudad
del país quedó paralizada tres meses
este es el estu de marihuana y está un
compañero que fue
aparentemente víctima de una golpiza
policial y murió después de estar 15
días en coma en cuidados intensivos al
menos 44 jóvenes murieron la violencia
es recurrente en cali
también la desigualdad el 65% de jóvenes
vive en barrios pobres el paro les unió
queremos cambiar
pero este año mayra cambia la capucha
por las urnas
apostará por el candidato de izquierda
gustavo petro como 3 millones de jóvenes
votará por primera vez la hija de petró
sofía ha estado haciendo campaña
partidista para incentivar el voto
una persona como tú
a sus 23 años carlos combina tareas
tiene una pequeña empresa es practicante
en una multinacional y está convencido
de votar por federico gutiérrez el
candidato de la derecha y no necesitamos
ideas locas populistas imposibles para
engañar a la gente
carlos es de un barrio acomodado de cali
su stock de carnes se vio afectado
durante las protestas cuando la ciudad
quedó aislada por el bloqueo de vieras
aquí te traigo unas muestras y que las
abrimos aquí el filtro considera que en
lugar de destruir hay que incentivar la
economía sí sucesivamente es una cadena
que creo que nace de las personas que
emprenden a querer a ser un mejor país
siempre firmes que no entren ya arriba
pero en colombia seis de cada diez
jóvenes no confían en las instituciones
por lo que para muchos la abstención es
la opción favorita es el caso de diego
no va a ir a votar el 29 de mayo en
parece más importante salir a entrenar
trabajar de mi oficio y pues ha sido
mejor y sin preocuparme de política o
algo así una nueva generación en la que
cada uno a su manera quiere dejar atrás
los traumas de la convulsa historia de
colombia
sin ninguno de los aspirantes obtienen
más de la mitad más uno que son los
votos necesarios para ganar en esta
primera vuelta los ciudadanos deberán ir
nuevamente a las urnas en junio para
elegir entre los dos candidatos que más
votos obtengan gracias por acompañarme
en esta emisión especial de aquí américa
sigan viendo france24
en la cee del color